so we've got the local elections
tomorrow all across the country but
yougov have been doing some modeling for
us based on polling over the last week
telling us what they think about 16 key
council races now you can see that there
are elections all over the united
kingdom for the stormont assembly there
in northern ireland uh you've got all
the councils in scotland out all 32 of
them for the first time since 1997 22
all out again in wales but what's
different about england is that there
are only some other councils in england
they're often urban areas including all
councils out in london so only 146 about
half the councils are out in england now
if you look at what that's the overall
picture so all out across every other
country apart from england now if you
look at just the councils that are up
for election here we start running
through what that looks like actually
the ones that are up for election on
thursday tomorrow are
by a majority labor 62 uh councils are
held by labour 46 by the conservatives
11 libdem 27 and overall control now the
point about showing you this about the
councils that are up for election on
thursday is that you can see that more
of them uh are labor so labour already
doing well where people are going so
harder to make gains much harder to make
gains so now let's look at some of the
calls that yougov tonight are making
let's start in london london one of the
best areas for london you can see
already uh they've got lots of targets
for the concert for the labour party uh
because there are barnett wandsworth
hillingdon and westminster all held by
the conservatives so if you look here at
what yougov say you can see quite a lot
of potential for the labour party they
think that uh wandsworth currently
conservative now leaning labor that
would be a very big result for the
labour party uh they look likely to hold
on to croydon and they could just about
take barnett and westminster which are
both too close to call tonight so this
is big news for labor it looks like even
though they've got this high base in
london they're doing well there are
potential there's potential for labour
to take some of the if you like the
jewels the conservative jewels in london
i mean ones with for example margaret
thatcher's favorite council i think is
it conservative for 44 years or
something that's now according to yougov
leading labour and that would be a great
night for kierstarma if that happened
but the question is can he build on his
base in london he of course himself and
london mp and start to reach out
elsewhere in the country well let's look
at what yougov are making calls about
for councils in the south now at the
moment you've got a mixed pitch you've
got no other control and worthing milf
and keys and crawling a key background
of southampton laboratory battleground
there uh currently conservative held and
hastings uh currently labour and here
the picture
isn't too bad for labour they could make
some gains so they could pick up
southampton southampton is a uh as i say
marginal that often uh flips between the
two major parties that could go labour
but then you look at hastings now
hastings currently under labour control
you have aren't sure aren't absolutely
sure that they're going to hang on to
it's more likely than not they say it's
leading labor but that leaves some uh
wiggle room that would be quite a bad
night if they lost hastings and then
those councils are on no overall control
well not much sign of progress in the
labour direction in those key races and
then let's look at the north
and here are yougov's calls uh for the
north here are three councils held by
label barry hull and called us out in
three uh currently under no overall
control and let's look at what labour
what yougov says about them you look at
this you've got
three councils which don't show the
labour policy making great deal of
progress bolton kirkley's we're all kind
of key red wall territory and then barry
that is currently controlled by labor it
will probably stay labour but you gov
aren't certain and then hull now that's
another sign that this is a big danger
sign for the labour party could they end
up not keeping control of hell they've
always had a strange kind of challenge
from the lib dems in uh in hull so it's
not it's not a traditional northern
council uh but then again calderdale you
look at that seat and it's only leaning
labour they're not certain that late
party will hold on to those i guess you
look at some of these names and they're
familiar names because they're marginals
in general elections as well barry for
example i mean i remember you know you
and me are always going to places like
barry right because they've got marginal
seats all over the place and if they are
not being shored up for labour at this
stage in the midterm do you think that's
a bit of a warning sign for a general
election or are we reading too much into
it
it is in part but i think what it
underscores is just how complicated
these elections are look it may well be
the case that we come out on friday once
the results are counted and labor have
won possibly hundreds of seats but
because where those seats are and
because they're in urban areas that were
already voting labor and because many of
the councils that we're talking about
well they're only up for election in
thirds rather than the whole council all
out well actually all of that just makes
it harder for the labour party to take
them outright even if they win quite a
lot of seats interesting stuff sam thank
you very much for that exclusive
analysis there